c'est vrai que j'ai entendu beaucoup de
choses qui se sont dites à mon égard les
choses vraies des choses fausses
ça n'a pas été évident et c'est vrai que
moi je suis venu ici pour vous raconter
mon histoire bien ce qui s'est
réellement passé depuis le début c'est
moi a ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que j'ai consultés cette voyante à
17 18 ans aujourd'hui avait un
aujourd'hui on est 24 se sent donc
j'étais absolument pas reconnu
absolument pas les marseillais j'ai
consulté parce qu'entre amis on se
disait à la voyante s'écoule bas
peut-être qu'on peut lire notre futur
ben pourquoi pas autant essayer
je suis donc enfin j'ai donc taper sur
l'internet bien voyante sur marseille
d'adressé juste vous avez tapé sur
internet sont le premier nom c'était
celui site incroyable j'y suis allé j'y
suis allé j'ai fait une consultation
classique ou tout simplement moi je sais
même plus si ce qu'elle me disait
c'était vrai ou faux mais bon je trouve
ça assez rigolo bombardier 18 ans avait
10 et 18 ans avec cette époque de
l'époque n'ont pas du tout dans la
coiffure donc à est absolument rien
d'autre qui se passe je fais cette
consultation et je ne vois plus cette
personne là je la vois plus ah oui je
continue ma vie je continue mon métier
de coiffeuse et à un moment donné donc
vient ce casting des marseillais dans
quelle langue
absolument rien entendu beaucoup de gens
qui m'ont dit mais non elle a usé de
saint pour passer à la télé non
absolument pas cette dame m'a recontacté
à la suite de la diffusion à la télé
quoi vous sert à pas elle vous elle m'a
rappelé puisqu'elle avait mon numéro en
fête nationale s'est dit c'est la jeune
fille qui avait que cela
elle s'est rappelée deux mois de qui
j'étais et sur tel est mon numéro de
téléphone
donc moi je vois pas où est le mal j'ai
eu un bon feeling avec cette personne
elle me dit qu'elle a envie de me voir
elle m'a vu à travers la télé donc je me
dis pourquoi pas je vois pas où est le
mal pourquoi parrot partir dans son
cabinet à ce moment là elle m'explique
voilà qu'elle est content de m'avoir vu
les seuils un petit peu de savoir ce qui
s'est passé elle avait vraiment une
relation un peu amicales avec moi ou
elle me disait bon bah c'est bien mais
maintenant qu'est ce que tu veux dans ta
vie comme tout le monde moi je souhaite
réussir je souhaite repartir dans les
aventures je souhaite trouver un shérif
qu'ils soient gentils qu'ils soient
fidèles j'espère avoir des beaux enfants
j'espère bien gagner ma vie comme tout
le monde
a ok bon bah plusieurs a donc on se fait
plusieurs rendez-vous à travers ça où
elle métier j'étais moi je vois ça je
vois ça pour toi mais je vous la voyez
plusieurs jeux c'est plus qu'on y est
riche et 2 mai fc2 c'était devenu en
fait car là c'est m
enfin le confident voilà une petite
présidente de gants une amie commune et
rés d'accord ce tube est oui une amie où
je me disais bon ben je veux mon bien
moi je vous raconte un peu ce qui se
passe je j'ai confiance en n ya rien de
mal et puis arrive un moment donné où il
épouse carla faut vraiment que je te
vois donc gym à ok qu'est ce qui se
passe chez vous appelle pour nous en
faut vraiment que je te revois je alors
moi je me dis pas qu'elle est un flash
peut-être car oui elle m'a dit quelque
chose je sais pas donc je vais la voir à
son domicile où la bassée pas aller pas
seul
d'accord allait avec une dizaine de
personnes parce que c'est comme ça
qu'ils vivent donc une dizaine de
personnes je me dis ouah qu'est ce qui
se passe je comprends pas mais tu sais
moi que tu m'as parlé que j'avais envie
de réussir ta vie tu m'as parlé que
j'avais envie de gagner de l'argent
inutile mais que c'est moi je peux
réaliser tous âges à bon mais comment
ben oui je peux réaliser tout ça mais
pour ça il va falloir que tu me formule
des choses que je vais te dis que tu es
jeux mais je comprends pas mais oui
c'est pour que j'arrive à voir si
réellement ça va je vais apporter des
ondes positives donc la chance va
t'arriver parce que tu sais moi j'ai des
dons en ok d'accord donc là à ce moment
là je me dis battue c'est alors que je
formule certaines choses moi le problème
c'est que j'ai une pression parce que je
me retrouve avec six personnes autour de
moi je ne connais pas des hommes des
femmes
je me dis mais qu'est ce qui se passe
derrière tout ça moi j'ai qu'une envie
c'est de vite partir le problème c'est
que tant que je formulais pas ce genre
de choses elle ne me laissait pas partir
moi je me dis mon demande de formuler
des choses mais qui vont pas avec ce que
j'ai envie parce que je m'estime attends
moi je veux juste être heureux dans ma
vie je ne comprends pas pourquoi tu veux
me faire du mal faire du mal à mon
entourage
oui mais même le même ma maman il va
falloir que je détache un peu ta maman
mais moi je vais jouer au hockey
moi je me dépêche d'accord et à ce
moment là je prends chez moi quand je
rentre chez moi donc déjà je sentais
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui n'allait
pas chantier - et à ce moment là une
balance des vidéos des vidéos comme vous
avez pu le voir et là je me dis mais
qu'est ce que c'est mais je comprends
pas moi j'ai pas de chute ou de demander
ça c'est quoi ça mais des vidéos d'auto
personnes d'événements des vidéos un peu
dans ce style là qu'on a pu déjà
découvrir d'accord moi je me dis mais
moi j'ai mon nez ça je comprends pas ah
si si tu m'a demandé ça mais maintenant
il va falloir payer au moins je n'ai pas
demandé ça si si mais maintenant
rappelle toi que costumes à formuler ses
demandes moi je t'ai enregistré